so one more game for the guy i normally
play uh
i normally play for two hours instead of
90 minutes
so i think that um
that allows me to play a few extra games
against one guy
i hope you guys will understand this
take steak so this this will be the last
one whatever the result
will be
okay
queen a4 check here wow
i don't think i have ever seen this to
be honest
so what is what is the point i guess we
can play knight c6
and bishop h3
this looks like one of the most stupid
things
i have faced in the grand field
so what is the point even i don't get
this to be honest
okay let's say we can sign
bcp2 okay
uh so can we can we play bishop d7 for
instance
so after bishop g4 he's kind of forced
to play rook d1 but it is probably okay
okay let's play bishop d7
just to chase the queen away
he goes to a3 but now i guess we take
and play bishop g4 right
yeah and he's sort of not in time to get
everything
so now i actually see you see his point
like he wants this uh
queen a4 queen is reset up which is
normally good indeed
so at least i kind of realized what was
uh
what was the idea of the move order he
played but i mean it's still
still not ideal i guess we take with the
knight
day extinct
and castles yeah this will be a long
game
he goes e5
which kind of means it will not be that
long game
like it's easily a very good move and he
is getting much closer to the draw or
it's a bad move that
kind of blundered something queen b6
looks natural
then he castles
um yeah and these seven will be hanging
in some of the lines
and what else i could play here maybe
there is not much actually
it would be brilliant to to make queen
c7 work rook takes d4 queen takes e5 but
when queen e3 is good there so this
doesn't work
yeah this is not fascinating i must say
okay let's play queen b6
and maybe rook g8
but this will not lead anywhere i'm
afraid
i mean we're slightly better but it's
not much
this allows bishop takes f2 right that's
what i thought at least
rook f2 rook d1 wins okay
yeah so now we probably take on d1
rook takes d1 yeah now we probably take
on e5 or
take on b7 first and then we play
forever
okay maybe rook takes c5 is kind of more
ambitious
allowing him to keep the queens but i'm
actually short of
time when i'm falling asleep so maybe i
should have traded queens
okay now this is not a problem anymore
[Music]
probably i will not lose this okay so he
wants to play rook d7 maybe
let's play rookie seven then bishop c5
bishop c6 runs into
okay whatever king g7
and then we start improving slowly
somehow like f5
and maybe king f6
we should be five so he's basically
waiting
but this is obviously a draw i mean it's
not that we'll win
after uh all of my smartwards
still we have to try this i mean we have
some hope like if we get h5 king g5
h4 then it could be unpleasant
i guess i will prevent rookie 6 check
just in case
another thing you could wander one day
is some rook
you know to first rank and then rook g1
[Music]
will be a checkmating straight
so now if he plays like bishop f1 a5
will be a straight
so i'll have to play something like rook
d5
okay
maybe rook e5 now
and uh let's say bishop is three
rook c2 i guess we can play h5
i only need to to avoid blundering some
8 after rook c6 bishop c4 and bishop f7
okay let's play bishop c5 back
as we are given a chance
then we go king g5 and h4
yeah bishop is three is there so it's
not yet a draw
i think it starts to look dangerous
actually
okay h4 so he cannot take and take on f5
as we can capture with chick wow this
is really this is really brave by him
yeah maybe rook d4 now or just bishop c5
i think it's very very close to
to be objectively lost for white
yeah bishop d6 i believe
rook d2
so now the g3 pawn is under attack
i can go there say rook e2
[Music]
now bishop c5 is also threat
it has to go to e1 correct
now i guess we take and play rook h3
and we are about to win a pawn
maybe not again because he will start
this a5 okay we go back
take stakes okay we wanna
we want one of the rounds
so g3 does not win yet by some miracle
[Music]
okay let's play four
rook c3 i guess
f3
okay now we bring the bishop to g3 or b6
and probably win
yeah he resigns okay that was tough
thanks for the games at least we managed
to show you show him
who is the boss here but seriously i
mean those three were
really tense so i don't know who this
guy is but
kudos to him for uh for playing really
well